Okay, I've got to start today by revising
a previous analysis that I've made.
I now believe that it is possible possible,
but it is still going to be an uphill battle
for Democrats to take control of the Senate
in 2020 really good post about this on our
subreddit from user homie Alex seven and homey.
Alex is completely right.
The reality has changed.
So our analysis has to change.
So if you've heard me talk about this previously,
I've said that there is a very, a real chance
of removing Donald Trump from the white house
in 2020 that's the presidential election that
in the house of representatives where Democrats
currently have control, there is a very real
chance that Democrats could extend their majority
above and beyond where it is now.
But I said that when you look at the Senate
and you look at the seats that are up for
reelection in 2020 that it didn't seem plausible
that Democrats could take control of the Senate.
And really we'd be looking at 2022 as the
first serious opportunity where Democrats
could take control of the Senate.
But the good news, if you want Democrats to
take control is that there are now some specific
races that have changed where it is still
an uphill battle, but Democrats can take control
of the Senate in 2020 so we're going to get
into exactly what race is.
These are, and we'll do the analysis and then
really after we do the case by case, the,
the race by race analysis as it may be, um,
it'll be important to do sort of a more overarching
step back look at it.
Because a lot of times it's not about individual
races, it's about the general way that the,
the election will go so quickly catching up.
There are 100 seats in the Senate, two per
state.
There are six year terms in the Senate every
two years.
About a third of those hundred seats are up
for election.
Next November class two they have classes
one, two and three splitting the hundred seats
up into three classes.
Class two is up for reelection.
That's 33 seats.
And then in addition to those 33 seats, there
are two special elections.
One is in Arizona to fill the vacancy left
by the death of Republican Senator John McCain.
There is also a special election in Georgia
because a Senator, Johnny Isaacson, who's
also a Republican, is resigning at the end
of this year.
So of the total 35 seats that are up in 2020
Republicans have 23 seats to defend and Democrats
have 12 seats to defend.
Many of the democratic are safe for Democrats,
Massachusetts for example, Oregon is another
one.
Many of the Republican seats are equally safe
for Republicans like Louisiana and Montana
for example.
But the balance of power often ends up depending
on a small number of races and there is now
a path that is not an outrageous one for Democrats
to take the Senate.
So right now, the a hundred and 16th Congress
Republicans have 53 seats.
Democrats have 45 plus to independence that
tend to caucus with them.
It's Bernie Sanders and I believe it's Angus
King.
Um, 53 to 47, effectively, Democrats needing
four net seats to take over control, putting
them at 51 and Republicans at 49.
The other scenario is that if Democrats take
the white house, the vice president becomes
the tie-breaking vote in the Senate, meaning
Democrats could have a net gain of three that
would make it 50, 50, and then the vice president
who would presumably be a Democrat if Donald
Trump is defeated, would become the tie-breaking
vote in the Senate.
That's another scenario.
So first things first before we look at what
seats Democrats could take from Republicans,
are there any current democratic seats that
could be lost or are likely to be lost to
Republicans?
And the answer is yes.
There are a, the one that comes to mind is
Doug Jones in Alabama right now.
This one is likely to be lost to a Republican.
Doug Jones defeated Roy Moore, the serial
accused child sex assault or in a special
election down in, uh, Alabama at the end of
2017.
If indeed Doug Jones is defeated and he could
win, but the polling doesn't look good for
Doug, that would mean Democrats need to take
back five seats in order to net again, a four
or a four plus winning the white house to
have the tiebreakers.
So are there four or five seats that Democrats
could take from Republicans?
And the answer is that yes, they are in no
particular order.
Colorado, Colorado is currently held by Republican
Cory Gardner.
We have former presidential candidate, a Hickenlooper,
John Hickenlooper who's running there.
He's up according to the latest poll I found
by 13 points.
That's one seat that is likely to go from
Republicans two Democrats seat number two.
This is one of the ones that's changed recently.
Susan Collins, because I believe at least
partially hurt loud support for Supreme court
justice.
Brett Kavanaugh, Susan Collins in Maine could
be defeated.
Now she is losing popularity.
She's still doing well in the Senate polls,
but she could lose.
This is one where the ground game is what
will determine what happens, but it's potentially
winnable and it's more winnable than it's
been in a long time.
Susan Collins has been in that seat since
1997 that's 22 years and this is probably
her most vulnerable reelection campaign yet.
That would be seat number two.
Number three, Arizona.
There's that special election in Arizona for
John McCain's seat.
Martha McSally was appointed there.
She has not won an election.
Astronaut Mark Kelly is running against her
in a recent poll.
Mark Kelly is plus two over Martha, Mick,
Sally.
The prior poll had him even.
It's close, but he's in it.
That would be seat number three.
Number four.
Now we're getting a little more speculative.
Tom tilling in North Carolina.
Uh, this is D, I'm sorry.
Tillis this is definitely one that is a bit
more of a stretch.
The polling still has Tillis ahead by about
three, but he's not super popular and RO,
uh, North Carolina is a place where we have
seen Republicans move away from approving
of the job that Trump is doing more than in
many other places, which means that it could
be winnable in North Carolina.
That's four seats and the number five, uh,
is Iowa absolute total lunatic Republican.
Joni Ernst is still polling plus two or three
in Iowa.
Her popularity is down significantly.
She's cuckoo for cocoa puffs and it is also
potentially winnable.
So those are the five homie Alex seven on
our subreddit also points out there are some
longer shots.
Like if you look at Georgia where the Republican
is only plus five you could look at Texas.
John Cornyn is not super popular.
I've said, what if Beto O'Rourke were to abandon
the race for the presidential nomination because
he has no chance and get down to Texas.
Could he defeat John Cornyn?
So those are a little more speculative, but
this is potentially winnable in 2020 now to
be thorough, there's one other democratic
seat that is not super safe and that's Jeanne
Shaheen in New Hampshire.
The polling is very close.
We've got to work on that one as well.
We have to hope that the incumbent Democrat
will ultimately ultimately pull away.
So these races require work.
And the important thing to now, if we want
to do a more macro analysis, this is looking
at it race by race.
The reality is that the general pro or anti
Trump sentiment pro or anti Republican sentiment
is likely to have a more general effect, so
it's not, you know, if Texas ends up being
in play, it's probable that North Carolina
is winnable and Iowa is winnable, et cetera.
If Trump's popularity goes back up, if Republican
attitudes towards Republican incumbents resurge
than it's likely a lot of these will not go
our way.
But still, if you want to get involved in
an individual race, all you can do is work
that race.
And if you live in any of these States, even
if you don't and you can still phone bank,
this one's going to require work, but 2020
the Senate is winnable